io non vorrei dire troppo per oggetto il
passo di testa già è una casa e noi cosa
stupenda
io vi osserva io servo sempre ltd
ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo video
sono fatti già oggi siamo tornati sul
turbo dismount non ho pensato di mettere
una una mia testa sullo mino a dirvi
ecco perfetto che non deve solo perché
nessuno scoperto sta cosa mi si stacca
sempre ha detto scusate cui i ragazzi
del toschi volevo dire che hanno
aggiunto dei livelli periodi sony per
gli bonus sulla sulla sedia sulla sei
perfetto
la cosa più bella ci sono posizioni tra
i bobcats ok
l'ho trovata lega che poi ancora non ho
capito perché all all bollette se
facciamo finta che le tette non ci siano
perché mi devo fare pochi problemi che
già senso che già è tutto strano sto
gioco quindi va beh è sotto 22 sì volevo
che andasse perfetto presto la posizione
di solo che preferisco avere ce la farò
qualcosa di decente ma che questa questa
posizione giusta ma ce la faccio a
prenderlo si niente intricati attaccato
fino alla morte proprio non riesco a
capire promesso auto palpando beh almeno
su questo punto sono furbo no
sì sì sì sì io santissimo fatto in
qualcosa di decente stavolta potemkin
merda per niente sono riuscito ad andare
indietro fantastico sono diventato la
piazza di del graggio va bene tutto
questo però voglio ancora capito voglio
capire come farlo decentemente in quelle
far almeno 200 e non c'è perfetto per
cento unico numero che non c'è è
fantastico è perfetto che col carpi ci
riesco riesco col camion e non riesco
col motori fantastico ho fatto più di
prima ma non si sa per c'è la mia testa
si stacca sempre che mi sembra di
tornare bambino ragazze ste cose da
piccolo facevo tutti i giorni quindi
solito ho fatto come prima col triciclo
però caduta meravigliosa tra l'altro
complimenti
proprio nella serie non me ne frega un
cazzo ma sono il più figo perfetta al
100 stavolta ci siamo dove cazzo ma la
mia macchina ragazzi che cacao che per
farsi era apprezzata al palo nega tutto
normale ai surepress che cosa è stato un
no vabbè questo è un ponte
il ponte rack i ponti ragazzi si fanno
esageratamente col posto seguita in
piedi giustamente seguita in piedi
difficile
oddio che cazzo ha spiegato e smontato
tutto io l'ho fatto un cazzo e si è
smontato sono affermati come si passa
roma non ho capito io vado vado avanti
si smonta il prof
a caso che serve mica una bronco fossi
godzilla non l'ho capita sta ora devo
passare dall'altra parte prima che si
smonti il buon tipo che parola vado
complessa perché mi sento pro in questa
ci riesco cazzo proprio
[Musica]
ma è un gioco più vado avanti più più
cala di senso invece sì invece sì invece
no perché devo andare storte ce l'ho nel
sangue che devo andare storto cazzo
perfetto e vorrei faccio anche sul
sangue non lo so quando le speranze si
perdono la cosa più bella è usare il
triciclo faccio ancora adesso quando non
mi parte cazzo no ciò credo per un
attimo ci ha creduto per un attimo ho
sperato l'impossibile stavolta c'è lega
e stavolta c'è tutto concentrato
si no ma stiamo scherzando come cazzo
fatto a cadere a chi cazzo è successo no
non si nuova per ma con vi stanno
prendendo veramente per il culo stavolta
se tornava indietro talian ceffone
arrivavi intime ce l'ho fatta ragazzo
soddisfazioni comunque fanno vinci si
rivela soddisfazione della vita proprio
questa roba per i ragazzi era stata
questa cosa ho bisogno della maestria
eccola qui perfetto maestà la posizione
giusta per sfera per fare un acrobazia
del genere mi sembra giusto della
partenza sembra che sia per cagare prova
bene io non te lo vorrei dire ma i
camion erano da lap dall'altra parte
però va bene così no perché questi
impregna troppo sembra che school e
ragazze è quell king
[Musica]
[Applauso]
qualcuno ma spiega sua posizione e corso
di yoga avanzato cosa ginnaste vite
parallele fa vj edition la prospettiva
di me stesso mentre sono col culo
all'aria e fantasma magari a un attimo
mi sono illuso dell'impossibile dove il
incastrato tar due pullman cioè
bellissima mostra track con questa la
vera forza amica che si è fatto apposta
e fabi c'è e farà di certo che saltava
altri 14 di camion non per dire è prova
ben caso fa a due volte lui si sente pro
ragazzi lo fa due volte non una casa
pare che non vi si sta ingrossando gli
altri ci finisce una volta lo rifà è sin
troppo agli autobus che questo è un box
ancora mi spiega perchè sto andando
letteralmente a suicidarmi perfetto come
non detto
cioè chiesto succedere ragazzi non so se
avete presente tipo il film piovono
polpette
ma è una cosa del genere adesso ci siamo
questo adesso non buono come riuscirci
invece non ci minucci nei ragazzi è
impossibile fatto contro le con la mia
testa che continua a guardarmi nella
maniera in crediti cazzo guardi vienna
ma mica questo questo è un calcio di
salto cosa erano quelli di peso vi
presento hulk 2 la vendetta è bellissimo
nome che stanno pregando passare in
pochi a chi cazzo
no no no no no fermi che quasi 3 lo
sapevo che mi attesa roma l'hanno
portata mica gli abitini
inquietantissimo a sta cosa provate a mi
è caduta la moto in testa fine di una di
una storia triste e sabato è tutta
demolizione celebri mente butto giù un
edificio fantastico non so che fine ha
fatto il resto del mio carne però si va
in groppa ronado di tutta la sua
magnificenza questione va per i cazzi
suoi
la cosa bellissima ma ring lottare di
nuovo l'albero oggi zio fa vi insegno
fare più di due metri in caduta libera
senza che eccola lì perfetto
presa ecco se ho avuto la paura tremenda
di non prendere la rampa vabbè gioco
consiste ragazzi nel cadere da un
edificio e caderci seduti più o meno che
permette vince chi chi chi riesce a
rimanere seduto non chi come me in
partenza già è caduto qualcuno se per
caso reso conto come minchia sono
rimasto in bilico se io guardo con i con
gli occhi miei mi viene male a
prescindere avete presente tipo le
persone che prendono il sole
tranquillamente in spiaggia ecco io io
lo faccio anch'io promo gli alternativi
ma la cosa più bella di vista può fare è
la forza che ciò contenta prima di
schiantarmi al suolo bellissima cosa ho
fatto una giravolta rimasta sola testa
sullo skate fantastico mi sono
affezionato autoscatto praticamente solo
io per di mezzola ten il resto del corpo
no devo schivare un treno con uno skate
board questa è una cosa non è che passa
al treno proprio mentre eco fra pero
invece loculo assurdo ragazzi ecco mi si
sta suicidando lo skate board però io
sono vivo ma fatemi una relativa in
macchina questi sono spiega perché
questo è più difficile prendono il treno
che è mancato è una cosa pazzesca di chi
lo sa più di qualche melone come non
detto non devo stare il sito qualche
altro
e poi ci schiantiamo tranquillamente
contro un treno ma sono dettagli questi
percorsi ci sarò con l'ultima che che
l'ultima dei livelli ne ho scaricato
questa mi sembra alquanto impossibile
effettivamente di fatto da una piena ok
ok maremma tua sorella però io adesso
sto qui sto qui finché non si sa se
grazie a dio mezz'ora ho anche preso la
rampa non non chiedetemi come non lo so
non ci crede nessuno che ce lo fa non è
possibile perché ora ragazzini che posso
concludere qui episodio anche se cioè io
vorrei vorrei puntualizzare che ho fatto
un acrobazia della madonna però non è
per vantarmi ma forse mi prendono per la
prossima controfigura di jackass
percorso ragazzi col mio culo all'aria e
la mia faccia sorridente in qualsiasi
momento direi che posso concludere che
l'episodio ragazze il video è invece
tornato il documento mi piace anche la
pace di facebook e condivido tratta
nella descrizione se non troveresti
scrive 13 vediamo subito da ragazzi